Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Schon mehrmals haben wir hier die Frage gestellt, wie ist eigentlich die Situation in Russland vor der WM? Und jetzt langsam kommt dieses Turnier unaufhaltsam auf uns zu. Und deshalb freue ich mich wieder mit Katrin Scheib darüber zu sprechen, die in Moskau lebt. Katrin, ich weiß gar nicht, was ich tun soll, wenn ich dich nicht mehr anrufen kann. Hallo. Es ist eine so schön liebgewonne Tradition und uns beiden ist gerade im Vorgespräch bewusst geworden, dass es vermutlich das letzte Mal vor dieser Weltmeisterschaft ist, denn es ist ja unter einem Monat nur noch hin bis zum Ende.
Da müssen wir während der WM nochmal reden.
Ja, das können wir sowieso sehr gerne machen. Ja, da habe ich noch die eine oder andere Frage an dich. Da kriegst du dann nochmal die Tage von mir Nachrichten. Ich bin ja gerade am Plan des WM-Programms. Aber gehe ich denn recht in der Annahme, dass du schon in voller WM-Montur in einem komplett auf Weltmeisterschaft getrimmten Moskau sitzt. Überall Länderflaggen, das Maskottchen hüpft rum, dieser Wolf. Wie sieht es aus in Moskau?
Warte, jetzt wo du fragst, ist mir gerade der Schminkstift im Gesicht verrutscht? Nein. Es ist ehrlich gesagt, dafür, dass es noch drei Wochen sind, bin ich ein bisschen verwundert, wie wenig man sieht hier in Moskau. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das in meiner Erinnerung damals an das Sommermärchenjahr in Deutschland alles verzerrt ist. Ich hatte da das Gefühl, echt Monate vorher wirst du damit geschallt auf allen Kanälen und siehst Werbung und Deko und sowas. Ich bin gestern extra noch mal, habe ich gedacht, fährst du mal nicht Metro, sondern erledigst mal einige Sachen mit dem Bus. Und damit du überirdisch bist und gehst mehr zu Fuß, dass du Sachen mitkriegst, es ist gar nicht so viel. Es gibt halt zentral in Moskau, vor dem Roten Platz, am Manegeplatz, gibt es weiterhin diesen Ort, wo sie so kleine Modelle an der WM-Stätte haben, dann haben sie da diese Uhr, wo die Zeit runterläuft, und dann wird es auch ehrlich gesagt schon ein bisschen dünn. Und ich war gestern in so einem großen Laden hier um die Ecke, die machen so Haushaltswarn und Gedöns, aber auch Garten, es ist einfach ein riesiger Laden für alles, was keine Lebensmittel sind. Und ich weiß, dass ich da beim Confed Cup Luftschlangen und besagten Schminkstift und was nicht alles gesehen habe, und habe erst selber geguckt und nichts gefunden. Dann habe ich die Verkäuferin gefragt, ob sie irgendwas haben, Deko, Fußball, Weltmeisterschaft, es sorgte so für gar keine Reaktion, auch nicht, als ich sagte, kommt denn da noch was. Gefunden habe ich so einen Metallkorb voller Basketbälle und Volleybälle, dann so ein Ding, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das nennt, wie so eine Konfetti-Kanone, wo so Fußbälle drauf gedruckt waren, und ein Rolliklopapier, wo Fußbälle drauf gedruckt sind, mit Krönchen.
Aber dann sind ja die Essentials schon mal da, das ist ja so ruhig zu hören.
Ja, die wichtigen Eckpunkte des Alltags sind Fußballbeschwerden. Ich war vorletztes Wochenende lang in dem Petersburg, da fand ich das schon mehr. Also da hast du in der Stadt schon mehr gesehen, die Aufsteller, die dir in alle Richtungen den Weg weisen. Genau so in normalen Läden, dass plötzlich alles mit Sabi Wacker gebrandet ist. Sabi Wacker Pfefferminz und Sabi Wacker Tic Tacs und Sabi Wacker Gummibärchen. Ich vermisse hier in Moskau noch so ein bisschen. Oder auch, dass du nicht einmal ins Restaurant gehst und so einen Aufsteller siehst, weiß ich nicht, WM-Lunch-Sonderangebot oder dass du keine Handywerbung kriegst, keine SMS, während eines Livespiels kriegst du das zweite Bier umsonst. Es gibt dafür, dass es hier durchaus kein Hinterland ist, was Werbestrategien angeht. Wunder ich mich.
Vermutlich wird das dann alles sehr, sehr kurzfristig in der Woche davor aufploppen.
Genau, just in time.
Wie ist es denn rund um noch ein bisschen wichtigere Dinge? Also, ich verstehe mich nicht falsch, Fußballkrönchen, Klopapier ist schon sehr, sehr wichtig.
Es ist schon weit vorn.
Aber WM-Infrastruktur ist auch nicht ganz unwichtig. Wie steht es denn jetzt rund um die Vorbereitung in den Stadien? Und die sind ja schon recht weit auch in den Städten drum herum. Ich habe gelesen, bei dir natürlich, dass man in Sochi kein Fernsehen mehr schauen kann aktuell.
Ja, das stimmt. Das ist noch bis zum 31. Also Ende des Monats so. Da bist du leider gekniffen, wenn du in Sochi guckst und dein Fernsehen nicht per Livestream, sondern auch auf den traditionellen Weg kriegst, nämlich vor dem örtlichen Fernsehton. Der hat im Moment immer von neun bis 18 Uhr tagsüber Pause, weil sie ihn mit LED ummanteln, damit sie da irgendwelche Blinkedeko machen können. Und angeblich soll diese LED-Fläche dann auch, es ist ja eine sehr gerundete Fläche, aber gut, die soll so gut sein, dass man da hinterher auch Spiele drauf zeigen kann. Wobei also der Verantwortliche da für den Fernsehturm, ich habe das nur in einem Interview gelesen, wo er sagte, ja, wir machen das jetzt alles mal und wir können dann da auch Spiele zeigen. Müssen wir halt schauen, ob wir die Genehmigung kriegen. Aber es wird erstmal insofern, wie der Fernseher abgedreht und auf Verdacht da gut mit LEDs verschaltet. Und was wir dann damit hinterher machen, ja mal gucken. Und ansonsten, also das ist jetzt natürlich ein extremes Projekt, du merkst schon, gerade in Moskau, die machen jetzt auf den letzten Drücker noch hier so ein paar Baustellen, damit dann alles hübsch ist, aber das ist generell auch gerade in Moskau so der Sommer, wenn du überlegst, wie lang und hart der Winter hier ist. Im Sommer ist eigentlich immer Baustelle, weil die allein schon die Zeit nutzen müssen, wo der Boden nicht gefroren ist. Darum auch so Straßenbaustellen, das geht dann komplett durch die Nacht mit Flutlicht in Schichten und dann ist halt plötzlich in drei, vier Tagen eine Kreuzung komplett neu oder so, weil sie es machen müssen, eh wieder Oktober, November wird uns nicht mehr geht.
Ergibt alles sehr viel Sinn. Na dann sind wir ja mal gespannt, wie das dann in drei Wochen aussieht, dann auch in Moskau. Ich vermute, du wirst ja noch ein bisschen reicheres Fanutensilienangebot haben.
Ja, das ist der Plan.
Und alles fertig sein wird, ja definitiv. So sah es ja aber auch schon im Dezember, als wir das allererste Mal gesprochen, auch schon aus. Also da muss man keine großen Stories drumrum sticken und dann manche Dinge werden halt mit Heißanlage gestrickt. Aber so ist das immer bei solchen Turnieren.
Und was ich schon noch sehe, ist so, also wenn du jetzt so die, weil du nach Infrastruktur fragtest, wenn du so die Meldungen guckst, die jetzt sehr kleinteilig sind, also gerade haben sie in Moskau wieder noch eine zusätzliche Buslinie eröffnet, die von der Innenstadt zum Luzhniki-Stadion fährt oder in, ich glaube es war in Wolgograd, gibt es so und so viele neu lizensierte Taxen. Also das ist schon alles auf dem Weg, das läuft, auch wenn man es dem Stadtbild halt nicht immer ansieht.
Was mich da sehr interessiert, aber das wüsste mir erst in ein paar Monaten beantworten können, aber da würde ich gerne dann nochmal mit dir dazu eine Sendung machen, was von der Infrastruktur geblieben ist, gerade auch in den Städten, die nicht Moskau heißen. Denn das hört sich eigentlich ganz gut an. Wir machen uns beide mal einen mentalen Kalendereintrag, dass wir irgendwann nach der WM mit genügend Abstand da nochmal drüber sprechen, was davon geblieben ist.
Das sieht man ja an Sochi durchaus, dass sich da lohnen kann, darüber zu reden.
Absolut. Jetzt müssen wir aber noch auf ein paar harte Themen zu sprechen kommen. Das Wichtigste zuallererst. Wie spricht man das WM-Quartier der Deutschen richtig aus?
Watutinki.
Watutinki. Und nicht Watutinki.
Nicht Watutinki, das klingt nach Takatukaland.
Tut es nämlich wirklich. So hätte ich es jetzt auch erstmal. Watutinki. Okay, ich muss wirklich versuchen, dass ich mir das angewöhne. Aber jetzt zu wirklich wichtigen Themen. Wir hatten ja hier große Aufregungen in Deutschland, weil Hajo Seppel ein ARD-Journalist oder freier Journalist, der vor allem für die ARD arbeitet und das systematische Doping unter anderem in Russland aufgedeckt hat. Ihm wurde das Visum verweigert, hat sich jetzt inzwischen geklärt. Aber hier in Deutschland war die Aufregung darum relativ groß. War das denn auch in Russland ein Thema?
Also jetzt nicht nur hier unter den Kollegen, die anderen Journalisten, die sich berufsmäßig dafür interessieren, sondern durchaus auch in den Medien. Gerade natürlich in der Sportpresse. Aber das ist ja auch für beide interessant. Für Leute, die sich für den sportlichen Aspekt interessieren und für die, die sich politisch interessieren. Und da gab es durchaus einige prominente Wortmeldungen. Jetzt nicht nur von denen, wo du es erwartest, aus der politischen Sphäre, sondern auch zum Beispiel ein hier Vasile Utkin, ein bekannter Fußball-Kommentator, der sich zu Wort gemeldet hat. Er hat gesagt, er traut dem nicht, er hält dessen Berichterstattung für nicht belastbar, oder wie genau er es formuliert hat. Aber die Blöße sollte man sich doch nicht geben, jemandem die Einreise nicht zu ermöglichen, nur weil der etwas berichtet, was einem selbst nicht in den Kran passt. Es gab, wer hat er das ausgedrückt? Er hat gesagt, dann kommt er hierhin und entdeckt irgendwas auf. Man hat das eben aufgedeckt, aber was ändert das denn? Guter Punkt eigentlich. Es ist das formulierte Aussitzen, was er da benennt. Es ist schwer abzuschätzen, ob das wirklich war, wir wollen den hier nicht haben, oder wir wollen auch mal ein bisschen rumstressen. Das ist einfach schwer abzuschätzen.
Vielleicht war es auch tatsächlich, das war mein allererster Gedanke, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Seppelt nicht einreisen kann. Dann sind das so klassische Nummern, an denen auch derjenige, der eigentlich das Ganze eingeleitet hat, nämlich dann Russland, in dem es das Visum zurückgezogen hat, dann ganz gut aus der Sache wieder rauskommt und eher sogar so halb positive Schlagzeilen hat, zumindest nach innen. Ich glaube, um die Außenwirkung ging es da gar nicht so sehr, sondern eher um die Inwirkung, dass man sagt, ne, guck mal, natürlich nur ein Missverständnis, natürlich ist uns Freie Presse wichtig, und plakativer könnte man das ja gar nicht, wenn man einfach direkt das Visum gibt, dann ist es ja keine Schlagzeile nach innen.
Ist gut möglich. Ich mein, du kannst es halt immer leicht anmoderieren, indem du sagst, irgendein übereifriger Bürokrat, hat dann die Gestärmte gemacht. Oder du siehst dich da gar nicht im Rechtfertigungsdruck, sondern sagst einfach, ja, hat ein bisschen gedauert, Missverständnis, wir entschuldigen uns.
Aber ist denn diese Haltung, die du da gerade geschildert hast, jetzt exemplarisch an dem einen Kommentator gegenüber der Arbeit von Hajo Seppelt, ist das stellvertretend für die Rezeption in Russland?
Naja, wenn du dir überlegst, dass die Rezeption in Russland natürlich weitgehend von staatlichen Medien geprägt ist und dann vor allen Dingen vom staatlichen Fernsehen, dann sind das natürlich die lautesten Stimmen, die sagen, warum sollen wir den, also entweder so wie Utkin, ich mag nicht, was der berichtet, aber warum sollen wir ihm die ganze Einreise verwehren? Aber es gab auch Leute, in der Wortwahl, ganz unsäglichen Kommentar, wo jemand geschrieben hat, den nicht ins Land zu lassen, das sei eine Hygienemaßnahme. Also wo sind wir denn da? Das ist die Sorte von Sprache, da kann man ja nur die schlimmsten Erinnerungen dran haben. Aber natürlich, ich glaube, die sichtbarste, lauteste, wahrnehmbarste mediale Berichterstattung ist natürlich, das ist der, der uns was ans Bein binden will.
Das ist ja echt erstaunlich. Na, was heißt erstaunlich? Vielleicht das falsche Adjektiv dafür. Aber bemerkenswert, dass trotz dieser, finde ich für Doping-Geschichten, sehr, sehr erdrückenden Beweisleistungen, also man hat inzwischen ja über einen Leak sogar die Dopingergebnisse, die Dopingprobenergebnisse von einem ganz breiten Jahreszeitraum bekommen. Das heißt, eine so gute Datenbasis, in Anführungszeichen, hatte man eigentlich noch nie für Berichterstattung. Und das ist dann dennoch beim betroffenen Verband und beim betroffenen Land und bei den betroffenen Personen vor allem. Jetzt mal ausgeschlossen, Vitaly Mutko, der hat eine bemerkenswerte Entwicklung gemacht, seitdem wir den Kurzpass machen. Er begann mit sieben Jobs und jetzt hat er nur noch drei.
Ja, Mensch, der arme Kerl, der muss seine Visitenkarten kleiner machen.
Ja, Wahnsinn. Das ist echt, da tut er einem auch ein bisschen leid. Hoffentlich fällt er sanft. Ne, aber was ich damit sagen wollte ist, für Doping-Geschichten ist es normalerweise so, dass man häufig nur eine Quelle hat und dann sehr genau hinterher recherchieren muss. Deswegen ist Doping-Berichterstattung auch ein sehr kompliziertes Feld. Jetzt haben wir hier einen Fall vorliegen, wo wir einen Whistleblower haben mit dem Rodchenko, der inzwischen im US-Zeugenschutzprogramm ist, aber immer noch aus dem Zeugenschutzprogramm heraus immer wieder Interviews gibt und bei der Berichterstattung hilft. Und wir haben eben diesen Leak der Daten. Das heißt, wir haben eine sehr, sehr gute Grundlage. Und dennoch tut sich eigentlich doch rein gar nichts, oder?
Naja, du darfst nicht vergessen, dass dieser Narrativ, wir sind unschuldig und die anderen wollen uns was ans Bein binden, dass das hier ja nicht nur bei dem Thema in den letzten Jahren sehr gelernt ist. Also der Abschuss von MH17, das waren wir nicht, und die wollen uns was ans Bein binden. Die ganzen Sanktionen, der Westen will uns Probleme machen und unterstellt und so Sachen. Und das mit der Krimannektion. Ach, das haben die da doch gewollt. Was stellt ihr euch so an? Erkennt das doch mal völkerrechtlich an. Also diese Haltung, die Welt ist gegen uns, gerade die westliche Welt, die möchte uns aktiv schaden. Das ist ein Erzählmuster, was hier schon öfter begegnet ist. Und ich glaube, das leitet deshalb auch bei diesem Doping-Thema verfängend in der Öffentlichkeit. Weil es eben nicht neu ist. Du kannst sagen, schau mal die mal wieder.
Ja gut, das stimmt wahrscheinlich schon so. Und es ist zumindest sehr, sehr schlüssig. Und wird es dann thematisiert, dass jetzt eben, deswegen kam ja auch dieser neueste, jüngste Bericht von Hajo Seppelt, hat deshalb eine solche Resonanz gehabt, weil da Fußballer betroffen waren. Und zwar auch solche, die im aktuellen sehr, sehr großen erweiterten WM-Kader der russischen Nationalmannschaft stehen. Wurde das denn mal thematisiert?
Ja, das ist ja schon wahrgenommen worden. Allerdings war das dann eine Frage von Timing, denn diese Berichterstattung war ja über Pfingsten und am Pfingstdienstag gab es ja dann diese Meldungen von der FIFA, die gesagt haben, niemand im aktuellen vorläufigen Kader, gegen niemanden gibt es genug Dopingindizien. Und natürlich war das dann der Dreh, den du hier meistens gelesen hast. Und dann vielleicht verlinkt zum Weiterlesen, ein deutscher Journalist wirft russische WM-Kader Doping vor. Also das wurde einfach, wie das ja dann manchmal in Zyklen geht, da war die zweite Nachricht dann, ist dann der FIFA die größere und hat das andere halt hier sehr überlagert in der Berichterstattung.
Genau, und sehr wahrscheinlich wird da dann der Hinweis darauf gefehlt haben, dass der Auftraggeber bei der Nachkontrolle von Dopingkontrollen in dem Fall die FIFA auch bestimmen kann, auf welche Substanzen hin untersucht werden soll. Und das wurde auch nicht mal gemacht, nachdem was man jetzt aus der Seppelt-Berichterstattung herauslesen kann. Diese Proben wurden einfach nicht geöffnet. Und klar, dann auf den bestehenden Tests gibt es dann nichts zu finden.
Also das Schlüsselwort ist ja immer dieses insufficient evidence, also nicht ausreichende Beweise gefunden. Das heißt, sie haben nichts gefunden, du kannst nicht daraus ablesen, in welcher Tiefe oder Breite sie gesucht haben, aber das ist eben die Formulierung.
Ach ja, es ist ein ewiges Thema. Das wird uns auch im Rasenfunk noch länger begleiten, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Da plane ich auch schon zur WM noch was. Mein Lieblingszitat dazu kam natürlich mal wieder von Gianni Infantino, der gesagt hat, Zitat, wenn wir im Fußball ein ernsthaftes Doppelproblem hätten, dann wäre das doch lang bekannt, egal ob in Russland oder in irgendeinem anderen Land. Ja, das ist natürlich eine prima Argumentation. Da kann man dann auch nichts gegen sagen.
Es ist geheim, weil es geheim ist.
Eben, ansonsten wäre es ja nicht mehr geheim. Die erste Regel des Fight Clubs ist, niemand redet über den Fight Club. Okay, dann hätten wir damit also geklärt. Doping brauche ich dann doch nichts mehr machen während der WM. Du hast mich jetzt dann doch überzeugt, das war zu schlüssig. Wir hatten aber auch noch andere, größere, übergeordnete Themen in den letzten Wochen. Und zwar auch in Bezug auf den DFB und Russland. Denn der DFB hat eine öffentlichkeitswirksame Reise nach Russland gemacht und sich da auch sehr für Menschenrechte eingesetzt, wo du einen sehr guten Kommentar zugeschrieben hast in deiner NTV-Kolumne, die ich hier jeder Hörerinnen und Hörer nochmal sehr ans Auge legen möchte. Lohnt sich wirklich da durchzulesen, ist meine wichtigste Informationsquelle inzwischen zu allem rund um die WM umgelogen.
Das freut mich natürlich.
Kannst du uns nochmal aufdröseln, um was ging es denn eigentlich bei dieser Reise und bei diesem Freundschaftsspiel, was es dann auch von U-Mannschaften gab zwischen Deutschland und Russland?
Die Reise hatte mehrere Aspekte. Das eine ist natürlich, wenn da ein paar Wochen vor der WM, also da war es ja noch ein bisschen mehr als ein Monat, so eine hochrangige Verbandsdelegation kommt, dann gucken die natürlich schon auch, was gibt es noch an offenen Fragen zu klären, organisatorisch, logistisch. Also ein Thema, was da aufkam, war zum Beispiel, wie stellen wir sicher, wo ist so die Mittellinie zwischen, man möchte Sicherheit im Stadion, man möchte aber auch, dass die Fans pünktlich auf ihrem Sitzplatz sind, spätestens, wenn einer die Hymne singt. Das war ja zum Beispiel beim Confed Cup oft schwierig, weil dann durch die Kontrollen so viel Rückstand an Leuten, an denen ein, dessen war, habe ich selbst erlebt. Ich bin auch erst einmal, habe ich beim Confed Cup auch erst ins Stadion geschafft, das war richtig. Also Hintern trifft Sitz und schon ist der Angriff, das war extrem knapp.
Wobei, wenn man sich das Vorprogramm in Stadien anguckt zur WM, könnte es auch ein Best-Case-Szenario gewesen sein. Aber ich weiß natürlich, warum es dich dann doch gestresst hat.
Genau, aber diese Kurve geht ja nur bis zum Angriff. Und ab da ist die Situation dann doch deutlich anders. Ja, das stimmt. Außerdem möchte man ja auch nicht das rituelle Reintragen des Hashtags verpassen, das wir hier beim Confed Cup immer kurz vorm Angriff gemacht haben.
Stimmt, sonst weiß man ja gar nicht, wie man drüber twittern soll. Aber da finde ich es gut, dass man sich da Tipps holt vom DFB, denn der hat es ja beim DFB-Pokal wieder eindrucksvoll geschafft im Finale, dass da keinerlei Püro und nichts im Stadion war.
Das habe ich auch so gesehen. Es war viele solche Baustellen, in welchen Städten, an welchen Orten dürfen diese sogenannten Fanbotschaften eröffnet werden. Dann gab es eine ganz große Baustelle, die mit deutscher Geschichte, Nationalsozialismus, Zweiter Weltkrieg zu tun hatte. Dieses Freundschaftsspiel in Wolgograd, was ja früher Stalingrad hieß. Also einer der geschichtsträchtigsten Orte im heutigen Russland und sicherlich auch unter den WM-Gastgeberstädten.
Es sollte sogar ein Friedensspiel sein, nicht nur ein Freundschaftsspiel. Wo ich mir die Frage gestellt habe, was machen wir, wenn da jemand eine rote Karte sieht? Was würde das auch sagen über ein Friedensspiel? Aber es ist ja Gott sei Dank nicht passiert.
Ja, und die waren ja auch zusammen in dieser Gedenkstätte, an dem Hügel in Wolgograd. Das sind alles schon, das fand ich ein sehr gutes Signal, das so zu machen. Und gerade auch zu sagen, wir schicken eine junge Mannschaft, um eben zu sagen, die ganzen leidigen Debatten über, wer ist schuld, dass es eben nicht um Schuld geht, sondern um Verantwortung, die aus einer Geschichte erwächst. Das fand ich, hat das echt gut symbolisiert. Dieser Gedenkhalle da in Wolgograd an dem Hügel, das ist einfach ein Ort, da muss man auch mal Leute hinschicken. Das fühlt sich auf eine besondere Art an, wenn du da stehst und dich da reinversetzt und dann diese leise Musik, die da auch eine gewisse Atmosphäre schafft, wo du das auch mal konzentrieren und ein bisschen vertiefen kannst. Also das finde ich schon alles sehr sinnvoll, da Leute hinzuschicken und das auch zu machen, mit Leuten, die vielleicht noch etwas früher sind in ihrer fußballerischen Karriere. Dann gab es eben noch die ganze Baustelle, Zivilgesellschaft, Menschenrechte und so weiter. Die DFBler haben sich hier getroffen mit, ich habe das genaue Wort vergessen, die haben das so was genannt wie Brückenbauer oder so. Also die verschiedenen Leute und Institutionen, die ihnen hier den Kontakt zu verschiedenen Gruppen der Gesellschaft ermöglichen können. Die haben sich mit Fan-Verbänden getroffen, aber zum Beispiel auch mit Leuten von Stiftungen hier. Vom Goethe-Institut war jemand da. Also wie kann man die Finger ausstrecken und in verschiedene Richtungen der russischen Gesellschaft kommen, um da Kontakt aufzunehmen? Das ist natürlich in sich eine gute Sache, das zu machen. Das ist wichtig. Ich nehme auch ab, dass das nicht nur ein Schaulaufen ist. Aber wenn es dann wirklich an die Substanz geht, diese Pressekonferenz, die Gridl und sein Gremium gehalten haben, war halt auch ein, zwei Tage nachdem hier wieder bei einer großen Demo reihenweise Leute, die die Regierungslinie kritisieren, verhaftet worden sind.
Und zwar mehr als 1000. Wir reden hier nicht von 30 verhafteten Demonstranten. Mehr als 1000 Leute wurden auf einer Demo festgenommen.
Genau, in verschiedenen Städten. Und der Thomas Körbel, der für dpa hier ist, hat dann auch sehr auf den Punkt gefragt, wie passt das denn zusammen? Der DFB schreibt sich das Engagement für Menschenrechte auf die Fahnen. Aber es ist eine WM in einem Land, wo eben, wenn du Kritik an der Regierungslinie äußerst, du immer noch mit Verhaftung rechnen musst. Wo wir das gerade, wo man nicht sagen kann, das war früher mal so vor sechs Monaten oder so, oder vor ein, zwei Jahren, was ja so ein bisschen über der Hooligan-Narrativ ist, damals in Marseille, aber heute ja nicht mehr. Wie passt das zusammen? Und die Antwort fand ich einfach sehr wenig überzeugend, weil er eben argumentiert hat, dass allein durch die Begegnung von internationalen Fans mit russischen Fans, man russischen Fans ja vieles vorleben könne und sich dann vielleicht deren Auffassung zu solchen Themen oder deren Blick auf offenere, liberalere Gesellschaften, dass der die Meinung im Land verändern könnte. Das fliegt ja komplett auf der falschen Ebene ein. Es geht ja nicht darum, die Bevölkerung muss endlich mal lernen, wie Demokratie und Rechtsstaat funktionieren. Ich glaube, eine große Teil der Bevölkerung haben davon eine gute Vorstellung. Die sind nicht der erste Ansprechpartner davon. Mensch, mach dir doch mal was in Sachen Menschenrechte. Dann musst du auf einem anderen Level einfliegen, sehr viel höher. Und darum hat sich gerindelt gedrückt. Und das finde ich nicht sauber, wenn man gleichzeitig sagt, wir schreiben uns hier Zivilgesellschaft und Menschenrechte auf die Fahnen. Aber selbst in so einem Raum, wo es wirklich ein konstruktives Gespräch war, die Fragen waren nicht polemisch, es war kein Boulevard-Journalismus, und dann aber trotzdem nie mal Ross und Reiter zu nennen, das fand ich ein schwaches Bild unterm Strich.
Ja, und ich finde es insofern interessant, weil ich vermute, das wird uns jetzt einfach noch häufiger begleiten. Wenn wir uns jetzt schon auf die WM in Katar freuen können, da werden wir auch genau die gleichen Argumentationsmuster haben. Und da finde ich das dann schon wichtig, darauf hinzuweisen. Es geht zum einen geht es nicht nur um die Fußballfans, die dann im Rahmen von vier Wochen nicht rassistisch homophob oder sexistisch beleidigt werden, sondern es geht um etwas Größeres. Und es geht auch nicht darum, dass wir jetzt ein Land umerziehen, sondern dass wir, wenn wir etwas sehen, was nicht mit unserem Verständnis von Menschenrechten übereinstimmt, dass wir die dafür Verantwortlichen benennen und damit konfrontieren. Und das wäre die Regierung. Und das macht der DFB natürlich auch aus Gründen nicht, aber dann soll man auch nicht so tun, als ob man jetzt mit der Fackel der Menschenrechte hier durchs Land zieht. Und ich finde auch diese Vorstellung, dass allein vier Wochen eines Ereignisses, in dem die Bevölkerung mal andere Kulturen kennenlernt, das wird in vielen Biografien schon etwas verändern. Aber im Gesamten hat das doch keine Auswirkung. Also ich kann mich sehr gut an die WM 2006 in Deutschland erinnern. Ja, Deutschland ist da mit einem anderen Selbstverständnis rausgegangen. Aber ich würde jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass Deutschland zum Beispiel wesentlich italienfreundlicher geworden wäre durch diese WM. Ganz im Gegenteil. Und es war auch nicht so, dass du danach besonders begeistert für Brasilien warst oder dass du gesagt hast, Mensch, die Art und Weise, wie die Costa-Arikaner hier gefeiert haben, das hat jetzt aber, so machen wir das in Zukunft auch oder wir übernehmen davon Elemente, eher nicht. Also man begegnet sich zwar, aber man bildet da eher eine eigene Identität raus. Ich glaube nicht, dass es so ist, dass aus dem Vorbeiziehen von anderen Kulturen sich im Großen und Ganzen etwas verändert.
Vor allen Dingen, wie du sagst, ist es zweigleisig. Es ist einerseits, also jetzt die DFB-Linie wieder, ja gut, wir können nicht reparieren, was selbst der hohen Politik nicht gelingt, aber andererseits eben genau das. Wir reklamieren Menschenrechte für uns. Wir reklamieren, wir müssen ja auch irgendwas dazu sagen, denn ansonsten ist es ja blauäugig, naiv oder irgendwas hier hinzukommen. Also es ist ein ganz komisches, nicht ganz wasserdichtes Argumentationsmuster, was da stattfindet.
Ja, und stimmt, das ist noch ein richtiger Hinweis. Natürlich kann das der Fußball nicht alleine reparieren und das ist jetzt auch nicht die erste Aufgabe des DFB, aber wenn man eben sagt, diese Werte sind für uns sehr, sehr wichtig, dann würde es auch dazu gehören, eben zu sagen, wenn man mit Regierungsvertretern zusammensitzt oder mit anderen Verbänden, zu sagen, sorry, aber für unsere Werte steht ihr nicht, auch wenn wir uns auf das Turnier bei euch freuen. Ach ja, aber ich vermute...
Sorry, ein Gedanke noch. Sorry, wenn ich dich unterbreche, auch noch die Sache. Einerseits stehen jetzt diese jungen Spieler in Wolgograd, junge deutsche und russische Spieler, sich gegenüber und spielen gegeneinander und gedenken zusammen. Und es hieß auch noch bei der PK, wir haben die extra noch vorbereitet, also die mussten jetzt nicht nur mit ihrem Geschichtswissen aus dem Geschichtsunterricht in der Schule dahin, sondern man hat sie noch mal detailliert wohl auf diesen Termin und diesen Ort vorbereitet. Und andererseits passieren ja dann doch auch wieder so Sachen, wie jetzt nach dem Konfett Cup, dass dann einer aus der deutschen Mannschaft einen offiziellen Dankeschönbrief an die russischen Gastgeber schreibt, wie schön und flauschig es alles war. Und natürlich war das, das war alles Tip-Top organisiert. Und wo es nicht Tip-Top organisiert war, haben wir noch was gelernt für die WM. Aber muss man sich da so ranwanzen und muss man dann so ein Dokument haben, was die hochgehen und sagen können, haben wir super gemacht. Die ganzen Westler haben nichts mehr zu kritisieren an uns. Und wir spielen nun also hier ganz klar in jeder Liga. Also Liga nicht nur sportlich, sondern thematisch, rechtsstaatlich und so weiter. Ganz erkennbar nun auf internationalem Niveau mit. Das ist unnötig und das ist auch ungeschickt.
Ja gut, und ich kann solche Dinge nicht mehr sehen, ohne es in einen Bezug zu setzen zur laufenden EM-Bewerbung um das Turnier 2024. Ich glaube, der DFB verliert jetzt schon alles darauf hin. Und da kann man jetzt seine eigene Meinung zu haben. Aber es ist letztlich Politik, die da gemacht wird. Übrigens noch, das ist dann die schöne Pointe. Dieses Politik soll sich aus dem Fußball raushalten. Ja, was machen wir denn, wenn der Fußball zu Politik wird? Schwierig. In diesem Zusammenhang würde ich aber sehr eine von deinen Kolumnen empfehlen. Nämlich, wenn es darum geht, welchen Journalisten man auf Twitter folgen kann, die in Russland leben und die nicht auf dieser sehr fantasierreichen FIFA-Liste stehen.
Auf zauberhaft benannten Reporterliste. Ich mache die gerade mal eher kurz. Finger in die Luft. Reporterliste der FIFA stehen. Ach, das hat mich einfach gefuchst. Das ist überhaupt nicht... Also ganz kurz zum Erklären. Die FIFA hat eine Pressemitteilung rausgegeben, dass sie Reporter haben. Einen bei jeder WM-Mannschaft. Und die werden von dort twittern. Und denen kann man folgen. Dann erfährt man exklusive Infos hinter den Kulissen. Und das ganze Setup ist null verwerflich. Natürlich, das ist... Die Aufgabe der FIFA ist, in diesem Fall für möglichst viel Interesse an diesem Turnier zu sorgen. Das machen sie so. Und das machen sie durch echte Menschen. Das ist schön. Und das machen sie durch Leute, die viele Sprachen sprechen, um es zugänglicher zu machen. Das ist komplett legitime PR-Strategie. Das ist Vermarktung. Aber bitte, liebe Leute, nennt es doch nicht Reporter. Wenn ich hier auf einen, weiß ich nicht, wenn es abends irgendwie eng wird und ich komme von der Arbeit und mache mir schnell noch, gieße da auf ein paar Rahmennudeln heiß Wasser, dann bin ich auch nicht Koch. Das sind einfach zwei verschiedene Dinge. Und beides hat seine Berechtigung. Aber die verkaufen es halt hier. Als griffen da journalistische Kriterien, also weißt du, dass du Sachen überprüfst, dass du es auf Relevanz checkst. Das ist natürlich überhaupt nicht der Fall. Im Gegenteil, das sind Leute, die exklusiv bekommen und verbreiten Informationen, die alles in einem positiven Licht erscheinen lassen. Das ist nicht schlimm, das ist PR. Aber wenn man Reportern folgen soll, da hatte ich tatsächlich ein paar andere Ideen. Es gibt einfach auch, ganz abgesehen von den Kollegen, die während des Turniers noch hierher kommen werden, aus allen möglichen Ländern, es gibt hier einfach reinweise gute Reporter, denen man zu Fußball und anderen Themen mal folgen kann. Und das sind nicht immer Leute, die auf Deutsch schwittern, da muss man vielleicht auch mal was auf Englisch gewillt sein zu lesen. Aber das ist ja so komplex nicht. Oder es sind Leute, die, wie ich auch bei Twitter in ihrer Einschätzung von politischen Sachen hier in Russland zum Beispiel, komplett unterschiedliche Meinungen haben, je nach Thema. Aber das sind auch eben Leute, die seit Jahren sich hier mit Sport, Sportpolitik, Fußball konkret, aber zum Beispiel auch Olympia oder mit dem Liga-Fußball in Russland, mit russischer Sport-Nachwuchsförderung auseinandersetzen. Und ich würde da mal anfangen, wenn ich ein bisschen mehr erfahren möchte, als nur, hier ist wieder ein Foto von einem Star-Fußballer, wie er sich morgens mit dem Kaffee in die Sonne setzt.
Ja, das ist eine sehr gute Zusammenfassung. Und ich kann da vielleicht noch die kleine Anekdote rauslassen. Ich wurde angefragt von einer der PR-Agenturen, die für die FIFA arbeiten. Erst über Twitter mehrfach, ob ich nicht Teil sein wollte einer großen Fan-Experience. Man würde dann meine Tweets auf... Also so genau haben sie nie gesagt, was sie machen wollten. Aber letztlich ging es darum, glaube ich, dass Tweets von mir embedded werden sollten auf der FIFA-Seite. Und es ging eben um eine Fan-Experience und den Leuten halt so ein bisschen mehr Wert bieten. Letztlich wollten sie halt, glaube ich, meine Reichweite anzapfen. Da habe ich erst gar nicht drauf reagiert, weil das ist ja völlig unmöglich. Ich kann nicht journalistisch arbeiten und so ein Kram machen. Erst habe ich gar nicht drauf reagiert. Dann haben sie mir aber sogar als FIFA World Cup Twitter-Account eine Direct-Message irgendwann geschrieben. Nicht mehr nur über den Agentur-Account, sondern über diesen verifizierten Account. Dann habe ich zurückgeschrieben, ja, ihr habt eigentlich eine E-Mail bekommen. Weil irgendwann hatte ich ihnen geschrieben, naja, die Sache ist, ich kann da sehr gerne mitmachen. Ich würde dann aber gern ein bisschen mehr über die Rahmenbedingungen wissen. Wird da ausgewählt, welche Tweets angezeigt werden? Was soll diese komische Fan-Experience sein? Und nur damit sie es wissen, ich sehe mich als Journalist und ich sehe gleichzeitig die FIFA als größte Ursache und Lösung für alle Probleme, die es im Weltfußball gibt. Und sagen wir es so, nachdem ich sie dann noch mal auf diese E-Mail hingewiesen hatte, die sie offenbar übersehen hatten, haben sie sich nicht mehr bei mir gemeldet. Und im Nachhinein habe ich mich dann aber doch geärgert, ich glaube, ich hätte noch ein bisschen länger einfach nur mal mir anhören sollen, was sie von mir wollten. Ja, du letztlich wollten die glaube ich Jubel-Tweets. Und zwar, die wollten was zur deutschen Nationalmannschaft sicherlich haben. Weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, ob sie bei mir da so richtig sind. Und definitiv ging es ihnen halt darum, dass die halt irgendwie über irgendein Tool geguckt haben, wer hat viele Follower. Und hat nicht in seinem Bio drinstehen, Journalist und dann haben sie halt die Leute angeschrieben. Aber jetzt, genau, aber sprich, ich hätte so ein FIFA-Reporter sein können, meine Güte.
Es war deine Chance, Mensch.
Ja, es war meine Chance.
Du hättest es rüber machen können. Aber wo du sagst Experience, ne? Das ist irgendwie, ist das so ein Ding? Ich bin ja jetzt ein paar Jahre aus Deutschland weg. Sagt man jetzt zu Sachen Experience? Weil hier der neue Ball, der macht auch eine Experience.
Ja, also in der Marketing-Welt, in der ich mich ja leider in Teilen meines Lebens auch noch aufhalte, da spricht man tatsächlich nur von Experience. Und ich habe auch schon Leute erlebt, die das ernsthaft quasi als englischen Begriff in einem Meeting gesagt haben. Ich hab's jetzt ja nur ironisch zitiert. Experience ist gerade das Wichtigste.
Ich bin aus Deutschland raus, als Marketing-Leute noch gesagt haben, dass man sich auf Goals committen muss.
Inzwischen ist es wichtig, dass die Benchmarks halt einfach cruncht. Wenn sie wenigstens so sagen würden wie Smack-It, aber das verstehen jetzt nur alle, die Casey Neistat folgen. Also interessant wird es werden, was die FIFA-Reporter dazu berichten haben. Bin mal auf die kritischen Tweets dann gespannt. Da wird bestimmt einiges kommen.
Auf beide kritischen Tweets bin ich sehr gespannt.
Ich auch. Das ist aber generell ein Gefühl, das ich habe, dass bei Twitter, also dass da viel Marketing gerade passiert. Ja, aber täuscht mich der Eindruck, dass die Russen auf Twitter sehr aktiv sind. Weil jetzt schon mehrere Marketing-Aktionen schiefgegangen sind. Mein absoluter Liebling, dass das Maskottchen da in irgendwelchen... Also ja, wenn man Porn daraus machen kann, da macht man es. Ja, das Maskottchen wurde in nicht ganz jugendfreien Posen dargestellt. Und auch eine Matroschka, die war allerdings auch tatsächlich unglücklich gezeichnet, möchte ich mal sagen, wurde entsprechend manipuliert oder darauf hingewiesen. Aber am lustigsten fand ich eigentlich die Aktion der russischen Fans rund um die Benennung des Spruches auf dem Teambus der russischen Nationalmannschaft. Da fand ich jeden als Vorschlag.
Also, es ist einfach generell ein Land mit einem guten, gerne auch dunklen Humor. Und ich hab vergessen, wer der Sponsor ist. Man muss ihn ja vielleicht auch gar nicht nennen. Irgendeine Automarke, die hier den Teambus sponsert, hat so eine Aktion gemacht. Ja, was schreiben wir denn auf die Seite vom russischen Teambus? Und das war sollte bei Twitter eigentlich dann schon. Die hat es schon eingegrenzt auf drei Sprüche. Die waren komplett vergesstbar. Ich kann keinen davon mehr reproduzieren.
Du kannst dich nicht mehr erinnern an Mit ganzem Herzen und dem ganzen Land folgen wir dem Traum? Ich habe das hier als Wand-Tattoo stehen.
Ich hatte da einfach nicht die richtige Experience. Jedenfalls die Kommentare drunter waren total großartig. Ja, ließ mal zwei, drei vor, aber lass mir den Schluss.
Du willst den allerletzten, also den Platz eins, den du genannt hast? Wir sind Jungs aus Russland, der präzise Pass ist nicht unsere Stärke. Wichtig ist nicht der Sieg, sondern die Teilnahme auf einem Teambus. Wer mit dem Ball zu uns kommt, der geht auch wieder mit dem Ball. Bus zu verkaufen, niedriger Kilometer stand innerhalb Russlands Preisverhandlungsbasis.
Schau mal, da habe ich das Wort Verhandlungsbasis gelernt.
Das finde ich super. Wir brauchen keinen Fußball, es gibt uns einfach das Geld. Sehr gut. Aber dein Platz 1 ist schon wirklich sehr weit vorne. Jetzt kommt deine große Stunde, Katrin.
Wir möchten einfach nur den Ball treffen. Super. Wie viel Sarkasmus hier die Russen auch ihrer eigenen Mannschaft entgegenbringen. Das ist ja auch bei vielen deutschen Fans gerade im Vereinsfußball ein beliebtes Mittel. So mit Frust umzugehen. Das ist hier auch echt eine große Nummer.
Wobei die Deutschen gehässiger sind. Wenn ich mir angucke, welche Schärfe jetzt schon wieder WM-Debatten haben, da fand ich das eben sehr selbstironisch, sehr distanziert auch zur eigenen Mannschaft. Mir ist aufgefallen, dass das jetzt schon die dritte oder vierte Sache bei Twitter war, die so ein bisschen hochgekocht ist. Ist Russland ein twitteraffines Land?
Ja, also Twitter ist hier nicht so groß wie Instagram. Es gibt also kein Tag ohne Selfie. Das stimmt. In der Moskauer Metro kleben in Stationen auf dem Boden Aufkleber, wo du die besten Selfies machen kannst. Ja, die Metro ist hier halt wunderschön. Das ist tatsächlich ein Fakt. Viele Stationen, historisch interessant oder richtig opulent oder typisch für die Epoche, in der sie gebaut werden. Wenn du dich dann damit fotografieren willst, du stehst natürlich den ganzen U-Bahn-Fahrern im Weg, denn die, die das nur nutzen, um zur Arbeit zu kommen. Dann haben sie so pinke, so tellergroße Kleber auf dem Boden gemacht mit so einer Kamera drauf, wo du dich halt hinstellst. Ich habe vergessen, ob es Photospot oder Selfiespot heißt, aber es steht definitiv bei, hier kann man die besten Selfies machen. Weil wenn du da stehst, hast du den schönsten Teil der Deko automatisch hinter dir.
Das ist ja Wahnsinn. Gerade, dass da nicht noch irgendwie steht, sie müssen aber 1,60 oder größer sein. Ansonsten sieht man es nicht richtig.
Bitte vorher nochmal Augenbrauen zu opfen.
Ja, genau. Oder diesen Hocker können sie hier nochmal für 700 Rubel sich mieten für eine Minute. Ja, Wahnsinn. Aber Russland ganz weit vorne. Wahrscheinlich werden wir das bald dann auch in Deutschland haben.
Ja, im Twitter-Debatten, das wird bestimmt auch während der WM lustig.
Da freue ich mich auch schon sehr drauf. Das Schönste ist eigentlich, schlechte WM-Spiele bei Twitter zu gucken. Oder zusammen mit Twitter zu gucken. Das ist das aller, allerbeste der WM. Aber ich habe auch viele andere Dinge noch gelesen, die interessant sind. Also erstmal, es gibt kostenlose Bahntickets. Und man kann, das möchte ich allen Rasenfunk-Hörern und Hörern ans Herz legen, ihr könnt, wenn ihr ein WM-Ticket habt, euch registriert, eure komplette Geburtsurkunde an die FIFA schickt usw., könnt ihr eventuell kostenlos zu den Spielen fahren. Und eine Fahrt nach Yekaterinburg möchte ich da sehr empfehlen, denn die dauert 26 Stunden. Das ist perfekt für ein Rasenfunk-Royal. Aber, und jetzt hat das Gebirn im Hintergrund geändert, ganz kleine Pause, ihr habt nichts davon mitbekommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Es gibt natürlich auch wichtige Themen rund um das Thema Bier. Es gibt Bier-Bann-Meilen, Katrin.
Ja, aber ich meine, das ist ja schon gut. Es gab hier erst die Berichterstattung, es gäbe ein richtiges Bierverbot. So wie es auch Gerüchte gab von einem Grillverbot. Das kocht dann alles total hoch und dann guckst du nochmal genauer. Und dann ist es irgendwie alles nicht so wild. Also es dürfen Städte an kritischen Orten, weiß ich nicht, wenn du jetzt einen Park hast und es war sehr lange sehr dürr und da ist jetzt nur noch trockenes Laub und Gestrüpp, dann darfst du dort während der WM das Grillen verbieten. Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass du das auch sonst gedurft hättest. Vielleicht unter einem anderen Gesetz, wo das dann bezogen wird. Das wird nicht so heiß gekocht, wie es gegrillt wird. Und das mit dem Bierverkauf klang am Anfang so, als wäre es wirklich in den Städten so. Es ist aber quasi ein relativ enger Raum um die Stadien und in einem Zeitraum ums Spiel selber. Ich meine, es fängt am Vorabend an oder so. Es ist jedenfalls eine überschaubare Zeit.
Aber es betrifft auch die deutsch ansässigen Gastronomen. Das war nämlich der Punkt, den ich da so krass fand.
Ja, das ist für die natürlich heikel. Das war tatsächlich auch eine große Überraschung, weil was hier relativ üblich ist, ist, dass es strenge Regeln für den Bierverkauf im Supermarkt, am Kiosk und so weiter, wo du die halt auf eine Dose Bier oder eine Flasche Bier holst. Das ist schon jetzt recht streng reglementiert. Am späten Abend darfst du es nicht mehr. Und nur in gewissen Mengen. Und nicht größer als 1,5 Liter Flaschen. Und was weiß ich. Weil Russland-Alkoholismus immer noch ein großes Problem ist. Und weil es verschiedene Versuche gibt, das zu bekämpfen. Zum Beispiel der Ausschank. Da gelten andere Regeln. Weil du in einer Kneipe, in einem Restaurant, im Idealfall soziale Kontrolle hast und Menschen, der gucken kann, schenke dich dem noch einen aus oder nicht. Insofern war das tatsächlich überraschend, dass die Leute, die für nicht allzu geringe Mieten, relativ nah am Stadion ihre Bars, Kneipen, so haben die natürlich auch eine Dispo gemacht. Die haben jetzt überlegt, so viel kann ich einnehmen in der Zeit. Dann kann ich mir ja noch einen Beamer kaufen. Dann kann ich ja noch eine Live-Band engagieren vor dem Spiel. Und plötzlich bricht denen das weg. Du hast jetzt die absurde Situation, dass normalerweise in Russland du bei Fußballspielen im Stadion kein alkoholisches Bier kaufen kannst. Nur alkoholfrei ist. Während der WM ist es aber so, dass in diesem kurzen Zeitraum rund ums Spiel der Stadion der einzige Ort ist, wo du ein Bier kriegen kannst. Weil es natürlich von einer großen Biermarke gesponsert ist. Die haben also durchgesetzt, im Stadion wird alkoholisches Bier verkauft. Und drumrum greift eben kein Bier rund ums Spielregel.
Genau, in einem Bahnkreis von zwei Kilometern. Also das sind da durchaus einige Bahnstationen. Und ich finde es vor allem auch deswegen interessant, weil ich glaube nicht, dass das so viel anders in anderen Ländern wäre. Das sind Garantien, die werden in den Bewerbungsunterlagen geben. Erstmal die jeweiligen Regierungen, die garantieren, dass es solche Sonderrechte geben wird, wo man ja auch durchaus mal mit Grundrechten kommen könnte. Habe ich nicht als Gastronomon eigentlich das Recht, Bier zu verkaufen, wenn ich das möchte.
Rechtssicherheit, klar.
Und jetzt ist das eben jetzt durchgesetzt hier in Russland. Es gibt rund um die Stadion, zumindest jetzt wird kein Bier ausgeschenkt werden. Es gibt nur am Stadion eben dann die Plörre des Sponsors. Und ich kann mir dann einfach nicht vorstellen, dass das Gut Katar ist eh eine Sonderregel mit Alkohol und so weiter. Aber dass das bei anderen Großturnieren jetzt dann anders sein wird in der Zukunft. Also da etablieren sich Standards, die immer krasser werden.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass es Russlandspezifisch ist. Das sind halt Deals, wenn du wichtige Sponsoren hast. Und ich muss dir natürlich auch widersprechen, dass dann da Plörrer ausgeschenkt wird. Da werden zwei Sorten von Plörrer ausgeschenkt. Eine in roten Bechern und eine in grünen Bechern, weil die Firma auch noch eine Marke hat, die russisch klingt.
Da lasse ich mich dann gerne korrigieren. Gut, und die schlechten Nachrichten, sie reißen nicht ab. Man darf an drei von vier Flughäfen in Moskau nicht mehr schlafen oder sich nicht mehr liegend aufhalten.
Ja, das ist so.
Das könnt ihr doch nicht durchziehen.
Nein, natürlich nicht. Das ist wie immer. Du hast diese Regeln, damit du im einen Fall, wo du mal jemandem was willst, dann eben sagen kannst, aber er steht doch hier. Aber ich habe jetzt tatsächlich, also jetzt im Mai und auch noch Anfang Juni, vier Deutschland-Flüge, also viermal eine Reise nach Deutschland und zurück. Und gestern, vorgestern habe ich mir schon sehr gewünscht, weil in dieser Regelung nicht nur das steht mit dem Rumliegen, also nicht auf dem Boden liegen, nicht auf Treppenstufen liegen, sich nicht quer auf drei Sitze fläzen, sondern da steht eigentlich so ein Beispiel auch drin, dass du nicht mehr Sachen, also Videos oder Musik, laut hören darfst ohne Kopfhörer. Und das finde ich eine super Regelung. Weil das passiert ja ständig und immer, das passiert sogar im Flugzeug, dass Leute neben dir sitzen, irgendwelche Candy-Crush-Runden spielen und es macht neben dir drei Stunden, 20 Minuten, die du nach Düsseldorf brauchst, bling, bling, bling. Man lernt ja dann auch sehr viel über sich selbst und wie man dann reagiert und gucken und seufzen und Fragen und Kopfhörer anreichen. Aber wenn nichts verfängt, hast du ja auch keine Chance. Und dass das zumindest jetzt an den Flughäfen, wenn du da rumst und wartest, nicht mehr erlaubt ist, ist ja vielleicht so ein erster Schritt, dass sich vielleicht dann einfach irgendwann durchsetzt, dass die Leute auch nicht mehr tun. Und was du auch nicht darfst, ist müffeln. Wenn also Leute, es war irgendwie taktvoller formuliert, aber wenn halt dein Körpergeruch Dimensionen annimmt, die den Menschen neben dir belästigen, dann ist auch das, kann auch dafür ein Bußgeld verhängt werden, ich meine es sind 700 Euro, 700 Rubel. Also eine Nullsumme natürlich, das ist nicht viel Geld. Aber es ist so der Anfang, da vielleicht ein bisschen was zu regeln. Auf jeden Fall, wenn ihr nach Moskau fliegt zur WM, hier nicht irgendwie danach spontan vor Glück auf den Treppichboden werfen und erst mal ein Nickerchen machen.
Genau, das könnte eben dann 700 Rubel kosten. Immer ein bisschen schwierig mit so sehr engen Regularien, die dann auch sehr willkürlich ausgelegt werden können. Aber ich fand es insofern noch erwähnenswert, weil es nur drei von vier Flughäfen sind in Moskau. Das heißt für alle diejenigen, die unbedingt ihr Nickerchen machen wollen, die müssen dann eben an den Vierten reisen. Und ich werde jetzt ganz genau gucken, wie alle Nationalspiele auf den Fotos des DFBs aussehen werden, wenn sie zu den Spielen fliegen. Da werde ich ganz genau drauf gucken.
Sollen wir mal nachsanktionieren. Dann machen wir einen Sammel-Invoice. Bestellen wir es gesammelt in Rechnung. 700 Rupel pro Nase. Wie viele kommen in den Kader? 22?
23 glaube ich.
Ja, das kann sich doch schon rechnen.
Ja, da durfte schnell was gehen. Und da will ich sehen, wie der DFB sich da raus argumentiert.
DFB möchte natürlich, dass durch Rumliegen Begegnungen entstehen zwischen den Menschen.
Ja, genau. Wir wollten damit Russland eine neue Kultur zeigen, das Herumliegen. Aber es passt halt auch so schlecht zu dem tollen Marketing-Claim, den man sich gegeben hat. Eigentlich müssten sie wahrscheinlich die ganze Zeit stehen und Dauerlauf machen. Sonst passt es ja nicht mehr zu dem, was man sich da ausgedacht hat in der Marketing-Abteilung. Ich möchte es nicht wiederholen. Gut. So, ansonsten gibt es auch noch warmes Wasser in Moskau, obwohl das normalerweise zu dieser Jahreszeit nicht so ist. Das erzählen wir jetzt aber nicht noch mal nach, sondern das verlinke ich. Die Hörerinnen und Hörer sollen sich den Teil der Kolumne, das Minimum, noch mal durchlesen. Das fand ich einfach interessant, was zu lernen über die Stadt Moskau und über Dinge, über die ich noch nie nachgedacht habe. Wie ist das eigentlich mit warmen Wasserleitungen, mit Boilern usw.? Es wird warmes Wasser geben. Es ist keine WM. Es ist eine WM für warme Dusche.
Na ja gut, bei mir im Bad hängt Gott sei Dank ein Boiler. Das fängt übermorgen an, dass es ein guter Hinweis ist, dass du es ansprichst. Dann musst du noch leerlaufen lassen. Ich muss mal den Boiler leerlaufen lassen, damit ich hier nicht mit Stinkewasser dusche.
Siehste, siehste, genau. Und ich werde es verlinken und dann können sich alle Hörerinnen und Hörer einen Eindruck machen, wie das so läuft mit dem warmen Wasser in Moskau. Katrin, ich merke es, jeder unserer Kurzpässe ist immer länger geworden. Ich könnte mit dir Stunden über die WM reden. Und ich habe auch immer richtig Bock, wenn ich mit dir gesprochen habe. Also ich komme ja gerade aus dem Rasenfunk-Royal. Es war heute Morgen ein bisschen schwierig aufzustehen. Und jetzt beginnt die harte WM-Planung auch mit Terminfestlegung und so weiter. Aber jetzt habe ich gerade wieder total Lust auf dieses Turnier. Das wird super. Ja, und ich freue mich auch einfach dann zu sehen, wie dein Russland danach ein komplett verändertes Land sein wird. Keine Homophobie mehr, kein Rassismus, kein Doping. Es wird so toll. Und alles wird nur der DFB gemacht haben.
Und ihr habt hier zuerst gehört, muss man ja mal sagen. Ich war als Allererstes im Rasenfunk.
Ja, wobei das mit dem, dass Russland danach ein ganz tolles Land sein würde, hat wahrscheinlich der DFB auch schon gesagt. Da möchte ich mich jetzt mit denen nicht konkurrieren. Katrin, vielen, vielen Dank. Das war mal wieder wunderbar. Ich wünsche dir sowohl, dass dir weiter noch gute Themen für deine Kolumne einfallen. Aber da hast du ja ein unglaubliches, eine unglaubliche Stamina hingelegt. Ausdauer, Entschuldigung. Siehst du, ich habe gleich Marketing-Meetings.
Ja, was soll ich sagen? Es war eine krasse Experience. Es sind noch noch 20 Tage. Es ist mehr langsam so, dass ich gucke, welche Themen ich überhaupt noch unter bekomme.
Ja, wahnsinn, verrückt. Wir schauen mal, dass wir uns auch irgendwie vielleicht während der WM noch hören. Und definitiv machen wir das mit dem Rückblick nochmal dann, wenn niemand mehr damit rechnet, niemand mehr an die WM denkt. Das war Katrin Scheib, ad kascheib. Auf Twitter folgt ihr unbedingt und abonniert den Russball auf kascheib.de, nicht ad kascheib.de. Und natürlich liest ihr die Kolumne auf NTV, aber wenn man dir bei Twitter folgt, dann verpasst du eigentlich nichts und da macht man alles richtig im Leben. Danke dir, liebe Katrin. Du auch und auch ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Es wird ein ganz schön ausführliches WM-Programm geben mit täglichen WM-Kurzpässen, es gibt Schlusskonferenzen zu allen deutschen Spielen und ich plane auch noch Tribünengespräche mit WM-Bezug. Wenn ihr das unterstützen wollt, dann tut das gerne auf rasenfunk.de/unterstützenundihr könnt uns auch gerne mal bei iTunes ein paar Bewertungen für den Kurzpass geben. Vielleicht rutscht der dann ein bisschen nach oben. Ich wünsche euch eine gute Zeit, bis bald, ciao!